(audience clapping and cheering)
- Welcome back, y'all.
Our next guest is a New York
Times bestselling author
with more than a dozen books to his name,
including "When I was the
Greatest," "All American Boys,"
and "Long Way Down," "Stamped:Racism,
Antiracism, and You."
Now he's debuting his
very first children's book
called, "There Was a Party for Langston."
Please everybody welcome Jason Reynolds.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(upbeat music)
All right.
I have to lead with this
'cause I mean, novels, poetry, nonfiction,
this is usually your field, right?
- Yes.
- This is new for you,
picture books, right?
- Yes, yes, yes, very new for me.
- What made you wanna do it?
- Well, I mean, first of all,
because there are
children that age, right?
I specialize primarily in young people.
And that goes from 18, 19 all the way
now to the youngest of the lot.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which are the babies.
And it's been amazing for me.
- I know, it's a different way, right?
What's the process?
How is it different from?
- It's an incredible challenge.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You've done this right?
- I honestly, when I was
like, this would be easy.
- This is.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, this is what every
everybody is like, oh, nah man,
this is like the easiest.
All you gotta, it's like 50 words.
And I'm like, yeah, it's like 50 words.
- Oh my God, it's harder.
- It's much more different.
- And to keep them captivated,
to write something like that.
- And you don't always know
what the thing will be that
will keep them captivated.
I think with novels there's narrative arc.
There's all kind of structure
and character analyses
and all this other
stuff you can do, right?
- Yeah.
- But with this, you get just a few words
to try to figure out how
to hit a particular pulse
with a population of people
that you don't always quite understand.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, yeah.
- Right, and so it's complicated.
- Yeah, so why Langston Hughes?
- Why Langston Hughes?
You know, to me, Langston Hughes
is one of the most important
literary luminaries.
I think that he birthed
multiple generations of writers,
and in this case,
specifically Black writers.
A lot of us came up studying the works
of a man whose work
seemed to be at eye level,
though truthfully was
far more sophisticated
than I think we give credit to.
It's the idea that there
is a vast difference
between that which is easy
and that which is simple.
Right, just because
the thing reads as easy
does not mean that it was simply made.
It usually means the opposite.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Right?
That it was very difficult to make a thing
that feels and reads and sounds easy.
And Langston Hughes
was the master of that.
- Yeah, to make it look
easy, and it's not.
Oh my gosh.
It's like a magician.
- You know this, absolutely.
- Yeah, I'm like, yeah.
Well, so the book was inspired
by this picture, right?
- [Jason] Yes, yes.
- [Kelly] I love this picture.
- [Jason] It's amazing.
- [Kelly] So much joy.
- [Jason] So much joy.
- So much pride,
so much going on in this.
Why this picture for you?
- You know, I mean,
first of all, the picture
in and of itself is amazing
to see these two icons.
Maya Angelou, Amiri Baraka.
So we all know who Maya
Angelou was and is.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- And Amiri Baraka was one of the leaders
of the Black arts movement,
a very important figure in poetry,
specifically through 1960s and 70s.
But for a lot of us coming up,
he was sort of like a OG figure,
somebody that we could look to as a hero.
So to see this photograph
and to see our two heroes,
two of our heroes dancing,
and to know that they were dancing
at the Schaumburg Library right uptown.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they were dancing on a cosmogram
on the floor in the Schaumburg.
And underneath that
floor, that piece of floor
were and are the ashes of Langston Hughes.
They're buried under that floor.
So when we talk about,
when we talk about standing
on the shoulders of giants.
- Yeah.
- We're talking about
people literally doing so.
And I would argue they're
doing it better than most
because they're choosing not
just to stand, but to dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Right, and so there's something to that
that we should all consider.
- And to continue to inspire.
- Absolutely.
What's the point of standing,
if you're not going do something.
Make your move, right?
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
You are great with words, my friend.
Yes, oh my gosh.
And your tone.
I'm like, okay.
Jason's newest book, I'm sold.
Jason's newest book is called,
"There was a Party for Langston,"
and everyone in the audience
is going home with a copy.
(audience cheering and applauding)